hello my name is evelyn neem i'm
associate professor at the department of
chemical engineering in the university
of waterloo
today i have the opportunity to share my
work on the sensing biomaterial
topography through mechanotransduction
in engineering cell niche
so first of all i would like to thank
the organizer for giving us the
opportunity to share our work with you
our lab is interested in the research of
tissue engineering and regenerative
medicine
the concept of tissue engineering has
been proposed in the 1990s in which the
motivation is to generate
or engineering functional tissue or
functional functional cells to repair or
replace damaged tissue in the patient
the concept involves isolating cells or
stem cells from a patient and then we
will culture them in which in retro
are generating our functional tissues to
replace the damaged tissue
another branch of regenerative medicine
involve
preventing cells
from patients or from a donor and then
we will manipulate or regulate the phone
or cell function and implants these
functional cells back to the patient a
cell therapy
so in both method one of the important
steps is to understand how to regulate
stem cells
the stem cell phase or the cell's
behavior in ritual
so as we know that we can regulate cells
behavior by using chemical like growth
factor cytokine extracellular matrix
protein or even small molecule or small
molecule drug
and
research in the last decade also show us
that mechanical factors such as the
rigidity of material or by controlling
the geometry of cells could also affect
cells behavior
our lab is particularly interested in
the topography of the extracellular
matrix
and we as well as other group has shows
that this substrate topography when we
replicate on synthetic material this
substrate topography could affect
different cell response
and in fact this type of cells
cellular extracellular topography can
find in many type of tissue these two
pictures are two
electron micrograph pictures i'm fine
from the internet but it shows a very
rich reservoir of extracellular
topography
find in the vasculature
another electron micrograph picture
shows here is the
um topography in the corneal epithelial
basement membrane
so this
evidence shows that
we itself are surrounded by a rich
reservoir of extracellular topography
our lab is interested in applying this
type of topography for tissue
engineering application so how can we
apply this topography for we have been
working on different type of application
so we have been interested in
applying
the topography on neuronal
differentiation
vascular application of vascular repair
as well as corneal regeneration
for this today's talk
i will be focusing on talking about how
does it work or why does we work our
group has been looking into the
mechanobiology in the topology-induced
cells behavior including to profit
induced stem cell differentiation
we find that to profit induced
differentiation is dependent on the
geometry of the pattern
an important component of the topology
sensing is the actin mouses
contractility and the focal adhesion
signal
so before i start talking about the
data today i would like to
acknowledge the contributions from
my research team as well as our
collaborator
so
i highlight
the
lab member or my um student on postdoc
who has contributes directly to the
presentation i'm going to give today and
also show some other of my lab members
both at the university of baltimore and
also in the national university of
singapore
in singapore so i have been principal
investigator in the faculty in the
national university of singapore before
i relocate to the university of waterloo
in 2016. so some of the work i chose
today are also generated from my lab
member my former member from singapore
as well
in addition to my lab members i would
also like to
thanks and acknowledge
my helpful collaborators as well as the
funding source that enables us to do the
work
we start investigating the effect of
topography on stem cells differentiation
and on the effect on the neuronal
differentiation
so in this study we cultured human
embryonic stem cells h1 and h9 on
different type of topography
in general we find that pillar substrate
usually will favor and enhance astrocyte
differentiation versus creating
substrate will prefer or favor to
neuronal differentiation and they will
also enhance neuronal maturation
the period of time required for the
neuronal differentiation is usually
shorter than
compared to unpattern substrate
or
other protocol
using a pattern substrate
we have also investigated
how to derive
neuronal subtypes
using a combination of topography with
other protocol
my former postdoc
can of time has
take this work to differentiate induced
polyprotein stem cells through a
two-stage protocol and i incorporate
topography in stage one which is the
lineage commitment stage as well as
stage two which is the maturation stage
we find that while in stage 1 in lineage
commitments that gratings do
enhance
the neuronal differentiation in stage 2
in the maturation day
stage
both
gratings and peelers will also help to
enhance the maturation and derivation of
neurons
to the investigator to examine the
derivation of tuplinergic neurons we
take we
we examine
the
expression of tyrosine hydrogenase which
is a marker of the pulmonary neurons
on grating we observe that there is a
significantly higher percentage of
tyrosine hydrogenase positive cells on
gratings we also have higher th-positive
cells on peelers compared to to one
pattern as well although it's not a
significant
not only that uh when we examine the
electrophysiology of the
electrophysiological functions of the
neurons we find that there are more
neurons capable for firing repetitive
action potentials on the patterns on
both the gratings as well as the
peeler's pattern
in our recent work we have shown that
using topology patent it can also
enhance the
derivation of induced neurons by using
non-viral gene deliveries to reprogram
mouse embryonic fibroblasts into neurons
in this study we reprogram mouse
embryonic fibroblasts by delivering the
bone factor to the cells with a
non-viral gene delivery with a polyplex
delivery
with only one dose of polyplex delivery
so after around two weeks we observe a
higher percentage of
cells expressing both
tj one as well as mapped who with the
highest expression on a hierarchical
pattern which means that we have 250
nanometers greetings patterns in
parallel on top of a two microns
gratings on the two microns weighting
and the 250 nanometers weightings we
also have an increased tj1 expression
and map2 expression
so again tu j1 is a marker for append
neuronal marker and map2 the mouse and
associated protein tool is a marker for
neuronal maturation
we also measures the electrophysiology
electrophysiology activity or functions
of the neurons and we find that
we
could detect cells with single action
potential and multiple
action potentials on when the cells are
derived on the gratings pattern
but we couldn't detect any
initial physiological activity on the in
the cells on the patent substrate
so this also has uh
give us supporting evidence that
topography substrate especially grating
substrate could enhance um
the derivation of
neurons or neuronal differentiation
however one is the mechanism behind it
so we hypothesized that nanotopology
could modulate focal adhesion
arrangement which will lead to
a rearrangement or change in the
cytoskeleton contractility
and
it could as a result of change the
cellular function
we start looking into the problem by
using human mesenchymal stem cell
specifically the neuronal
differentiation of new human
mesenchymal stem cells as a model cell
system to investigate what is the
mechanism behind topology induced
differentiation
as during the differentiation we
observed a high expression of
phosphorylated focal adhesion kinase
we would like to apply a small molecule
inhibitor the pf573228
to specifically
inhibit
the
phosphorylation of the tyrosine 397 site
of focal adhesion kinase
using this mormon molecule inhibitor we
can inhibit
the phosphorylation of the tyrosine 397
site of fak
and
we find that the neuronal marker that
usually is upregulated by the top office
induced differentiation is abolished
when we inhibit the phosphorylation at
the tyrosine 397 site
to further show the rules of focal
adhesion kinase
played in the topography induced
differentiation
we also use srna to lock down
the
fake
expression in the in the human
mesenchymal stem cell indeed we find
that with the
knockdown of the focal adhesion kinase
we also observe a significant reduced uh
reduction in the neuronal marker
expressions that we usually will see in
the topography induced differentiation
in a collaboration with our collaborator
professor lu roma in johns hopkins
university we use superfact which is an
engineering mutant inducing an increased
auto catalytic phosphorylation of fak
using superfact we find that it actually
increase the sensitivity of the human
mesenchymal stem cells to topology
sensing
in which the topology-induced neuronal
marker expression is significantly
higher when is exposed to the topography
so it
further shows the significant
involvement of focal adhesion kinase in
the topography sensing
another
question we would like to ask is what is
the role of the force sensing in terms
of the
force mediated signal by the
cytoskeleton contractility
so in this experiment we also applied
two other small molecule inhibitor the y
compound which is the rock inhibitor
input inhibiting the rho kinase effector
as well as bipistantin which is our
inhibitor for non-muscle monsoons too
when we apply these two inhibitors to
inhibit the cytoskeleton contractility
we see the nuance marker that usually
expressed
in the cells
in the cells undergoing topography
induced differentiation those neuronal
markers expression is being abolished
it shows that the
topopathy induced
differentiation does require
cytoskeleton contractility
we would also like to investigate the
involvement of cytoskeleton
contractility in the embryonic stem cell
differentiation or nanotopography
my other student solila has taken this
work and she investigates the role of
lactomouse's contractility during the
early phase of topology in mediated
neuronal differentiation and should look
at the expression in day 1 day 4 and day
7 after the neuronal differentiation has
started
so in polar protein stem cells in
embryonic stem cells
the
when they are undifferentiated the um
they have very low expression of
stress fiber or cytoskeleton
contractility so both effecting
expression as well as the phosphorylated
mouse and light chains expression is
quite low
during the differentiation process the
formation of stress fiber as well as the
phosphorylated myosin nitrate expression
will increase as the cell starts to
differentiate
so during this process we find that the
cells culture on the 250 meter nano
greetings
will have stress fiber appeared as early
as day one so the
cytoskeleton contractility
developed much earlier on
the nano gratings
very interestingly when we applied the
inhibitor
the y compounds to
the rock inhibitor
we actually observed as the rock
inhibitor
with the presence of walk inhibitor
we have a higher expression of tj1 in
the human embryonic stem cells
contouring on the nano gratings
and in this case it means that when the
ectomyosin the contractility is
decreased we actually have a higher
expression of
the nuance
meanwhile
while
in the presence of bible stanton when we
inhibit the ethomolysis contractility it
actually leads to a reduction in map2
expression
so
these two data series should be
contradicting but if we think about
disease it is actually agreeing with
what other researchers has find in the
literature as well
in the literature
as a researcher has found that using a
soft substrate will help to enhance and
induce neuronal differentiation
and in the soft substrate the cells
will have would develop a lower
actual muscle contractility in response
to the softer environment which is
similar to when we apply a low dose of
y compounds to lower the actins molson's
contractility and
in response the combination of
that rock inhibitor with the
nano gratings we observe a higher
expression of tj1
however as what we have observed in
in our human mesenchymal stem cell study
um as the electromagnet's contractility
is needed for
the differentiation for the topography
mediated differentiation if we
inhibit the actual muscles contractility
by bipistatin we will not be able to
observe the maturation of the neurons
and the expression of map2
so when we are talking about the
cytoskeleton contractility we would like
to quantitative
examines the actual mouses contractility
and the traction force of the cells
culture on the greetings
in collaboration with our collaborator
dr king regime
in
bioinformatics institute in singapore
we have developed we have developed this
3d traction stress measurement system
on on two microns ratings
so first we observe that
the cells on these micro gratings exert
a significantly higher force that is in
the parallel directions to the gratings
another interesting study we will
observation that we have
is that the cells actually
exert a higher traction force on each of
the focal adhesion
so but two slides ago we mentioned i
mentioned that
the low contractility of the um
the lower contractility will help to
enhance neural differentiation
indeed this is also what we observed
because uh or what we speculate because
when the cells are cultured on the flat
on patent substrate we see a lot
many more focal adhesion
but on the
grating substrate
we observe fewer number of focal
adhesion
so what does the traction force
per each focal adhesion is increased
when we investigate the overall
contractility we actually find the
overall contractility is lower in the
cells on the greetings
which also agree with our speculations
that the grating substrate
will
lead the cells to have a lower
contractility which also is one of the
reason why it could contribute to the
enhancement in the neuronal
differentiation
we also hypothesize that the change in
the cytoskeleton may also affect
the nucleus the genes
the gene regulation in the nucleus so we
also walk into the nucleus morphology at
the early stage of differentiation
so on the cells culture on the nano and
macros gratings we find that the nucleus
also are significantly elongated
on
the
on the grating substrate
and the nucleus is also aligned along
the greetings direction
we also observe that there's an
increased x3 k9 mne3 expression
in the um in the early phase of the
neuronal differentiation when we culture
the cells on many cultures the embryonic
stem cells on 250 meter nanoscrating
so in summary
we speculate how topology influenced
cells differentiation or cell behavior
the true mechanism has followed topology
signals are transduced through focal
adhesion kinase signaling
and to profit induced differentiation is
mediated by
actual myosin's contractility
and both
this actual molecule's contractility as
well as the focal adhesion signaling is
important in topology sensing
when we decrease
active milestones contractility of the
cells it could enhance the
neuronal lineage commitment so there's
more tgg1 positive cells
however if we
inhibit
the
actin molson's contractility it could
also inhibit the neuronal maturation
so map2 expressions the maturation of
the neurons is actually depends on
actual myosin's contractility
with using a 3d
threshold force measurement we find that
cells on gratings exert an isotropic
traction stress
on the gratings
with
overall lower contractilities when the
cells are cultured on grating substrate
and we also find that the force
transduced to the nucleus
will lead to a change in nuclear
shape and morphology and it could also
affect
the gene regulations leading to
subsequent change in
cell behavior as well as
changing the protein expression
so with that i hope that
i have convinced you that
the
it's important to consider topography or
the surface structure of a material
and i am also able to convince you that
topography could significantly affect
cell behavior
and such as stem cells differentiation
with that i would like to thank my
student again and also my um my current
student and also my former student that
has contributes to the work our
collaborator funding source and thank
you very much for your attention